Scientists published a new study on...penis
size........oh here we go.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews. When
you think of things that might cause an affair,
a big penis isn't usually one of them. The
cultural narrative is basically: "the bigger
the sexier, the bigger the better!" But according
to a new study published in PLOS One last
week, big penises might be causing some...big
problems. US and Kenyan researchers studied
around 600 couples living around Lake Victoria
in Kenya and found that for every extra inch
of length in her husband's penis, the likelihood
that the wife would cheat increased by almost
1 ½ times. Their qualitative data found the
same results: women associated large penises
with pain and discomfort during sex, which,
oooobviously, makes things a lot less enjoyable.
Women in the study were quoted saying things
like:
"...some penises may be large yet my vagina
is small, when he tries to insert it inside,
it hurts so much that I will have to look
for another man who has a smaller one and
can do it in a way I can enjoy".
Well....shoot. Can't argue with that can you?
Well, except from the perspective that it's
really strange to solve this problem by CHEATING
ON SOMEONE. I think that's what I find strangest
about this story. Then again, various forms
of dissatisfaction with the relationship or
the sex is a huge reason why people cheat
in general, so I guess it shouldn't come as
a huge surprise. The researchers also looked
at other causes of having an affair - the
main ones they found were.....domestic violence---huge
shocker there---and denial of the woman's
preferred sexual positions. Man, these guys
sound like real keepers, amirite?
What does this research mean? It tells us
something the sexual health world has been
saying all along: size matters, but not in
the way you think it does. What's most important
is the way that your bodies *fit together*,
not about how "large" someone is. Vaginas
come in different sizes as well -- just like
penises, they get erect when aroused and some
are longer, some are shorter. A short vagina
paired with a long penis is a undoubtedly
a recipe for very painful, unenjoyable sex.
In addition to stretching things in an unpleasant
way, it can hit the cervix and jar the ovaries.
Not an uncommon thing - and it can really
hurt!
The researchers concluded the report by ever-so-gently
discouraging men from pursuing penis augmentations,
since it's counterproductive to pleasure for
both parties. They also noted that they hope
the findings encourage men to understand that
having a large penis doesn't make for better
sex or better ability to please a partner.
Especially not if you're straight, since the
vast majority of women can't orgasm vaginally
anyway. Yeaaaaah, myth bustin!
Thanks for joining me for DNews everyone,
we'll see you next time with more science
updates!